all right
all right are you ready for your
headliner comes Comedy Club
awesome
[Applause]
all right here we go show time
what are we dealing with tonight
who are these people
oh blue noted on their phones sisters no
who's that that look straight
is that my brother
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
I don't know I hear
now I hear a few people
okay now it's not thank you Miss
two people said Gareth the rest you said
Gary
um
yeah there's no material this evening uh
so if it's garbage you know that's
partially your fault so and I like that
I feel good about that
together yeah all right
doesn't feel super romantic right off
the bat feels uh going good
going all right yeah it feels like it's
going all right
feels like the right answer it's going
now he's holding her hand he's like come
on baby let's pretend come on
come on
be the beard you promised you'd be you
said
you'd fulfill that rule
how did you meet
work what is work
[Music]
your gardeners
gardeners for the city
so this is taking on a bit of a porny
Vibe honestly
a couple of gardeners like Adam and Eve
kind of just sort of we met in a garden
and then can I I would like to picture
that one day you sort of parted some
shrubs Miss and you were like who the
[__] is that tall drink of water over
there a man Mirage or is that for Mama
and then what's the first move
you like you like whacking weeds huh
how long you been together
four and a half years okay marriage
maybe hopefully oh I like that you're
acting like you're in the passenger seat
of this sir
I hope so you never know if it's
possible you'd never
it's impossible to tell isn't it right
all right well that's cool well good for
you and is sure any animals anything
like that
okay I'm gonna
sometimes you go one question too far in
this stuff and that's
that's just kind of how it is you just
you're like I'll ask one more question
you're like any animals and he just like
a gun on his hips at frogs
what a gardener pet frogs is
how many frogs I must know four one for
each year we've been together
each year we get another frog
like rings in a tree
how long have you two been together
we'll go count our frogs you're right
sorry I asked wow five years that's
great still not married we don't know if
it's possible
the [__]
good for you that's hot
turned on by that sir
yeah it's hot right yeah a little frog
left yeah you're holding hands were you
holding hands before I started talking
to them did you realize
once I started ripping on him you're
like give me that [__] hand give me
the hand give me the hand give me the
hand oh there we go
how did you two meet
okay and um when I said how did you two
meet and you answered with a number what
happened there I didn't say how many
frogs have you been together
I said how did you two me
eight frogs
we've been together for eight frogs
how's that so
together
now friends
how did how did this what's that we are
entrepreneurs from Central Valley you're
entrepreneurs from Central Valley
entrepreneurs is my favorite job that's
like
on like dating apps and that'll be
someone's job and you're like unemployed
okay
[Applause]
I'm an entrepreneur sure you are yeah
so are you entrepreneurs who work
together
you're separate entrepreneurs
across so you one would think that this
should not be a friendship entrepreneurs
across the street from each other this
feels like it should be Rivals
he owns a record store I own a pizzeria
you guys know that somebody's already
beaten you to that territory right
to me entrepreneur maybe it's just my
version of entrepreneurs as like an
inventor to some extent you're not that
no you just have a record place yes and
you a pizza place and you guys are like
we both sell circles that people like
this can work
[Applause]
and is that what your entrepreneurship
is based on your pizza and your records
yes yes
so I just not to dig in too deep but one
would think that you were just people
who ran businesses
business owners now what about
what takes you
for business owner
yeah this is what happens when you're in
San Francisco people like I actually
I've invented a business look okay
I'm not getting laid after owning a
pizza shop I'm an entrepreneur
and then is that how you met across the
street you're like this son of a [__]
is a real entrepreneur records nobody's
ever heard of this idea before
is that what happened
they're alcoholics yeah
[Applause]
the simplest way to get one of my crowds
on your side is good we have drinking
problems
it started off weird but then they want
me over with their drinking issue
you're giving off strong you don't want
to talk to me energy sir and that for me
makes me want to talk to you your mask
and your shirt match
you're looking away every time there's a
lull you're like don't look at him and
then he his vision is based on movement
he will not be able to pick up on you
what do you do for work sir
unemployed okay all right you know sir
I've got a solution to that just say
you're an entrepreneur
you don't need to say that anymore
together
yes yeah how long
uh-huh okay yeah meet how
an app that's how people do it it's
especially in this [__] town
um that's how these guys met
yeah they met on bump up credentials um
which one which app
I'm sorry what the [__] is it called
coffee meets Bagel all right there's
officially too many dating apps when one
of them is called coffee meets bagel I
know how it happened you were the only
two on it and you're like oh [__]
someone else is on this [__]
the headquarters of coffee meets Bagel
we're like guys you're not gonna believe
this we've got a second person signing
up
has anyone here ever heard of coffee
meets pickle Jesus Christ
What a Sad Town what a sad sad town
[Applause]
did anyone else hear me on coffee meets
bagel
well that's interesting isn't it
I can tell it's going well too because
you two just high-fived which is the
sign of a couple in love
[Applause]
[__] yeah so how many options are you
given a day
so they give you
women get more than men
how many is in you how many do you get a
day 10 and you got what like five what
the [__]
it's just like how the account the
economy Works kind of they're just like
women get half as much that's what
that's equality in America and that's
what we're gonna go with
there we go fair fair okay all right oh
it sounds like dog [__] I'll be honest I
really I'm happy for you too and then
have you deleted coffee meets Bagels
since yeah you know she hasn't
acknowledged she hasn't answered the
question sir you answered the question
immediately like oh yeah it's gone she
was like
women get five
professionally for sure
anyone have a weird story of how they
met anyone got a crazy story outside of
that weird job yeah what do you got
we both went to the concert for previous
significant others oh spicy and you were
together at the time when you're at the
concert yeah
yep right yep and then
a girlfriend two weeks later like hey I
met this person at the concert and then
they introduced us what the [__]
so you independently go then your
significant others meet each other at
the concert well how we were I'm a
balcony
they were standing on the rail uh
her boyfriend if he could move so that
my girlfriend could get a better View
and then he was like yeah sure yeah sure
should I [__] her
[Applause]
yeah you want me to move so she has a
better view what if I just [__] her and
take her away from you is that a good
plan too
how about this I'll do you one better
I'm gonna start dating her and uh yeah
is that good for you yeah yeah no
problem no she deserves a better View
and a better relationship she deserves a
lot of better [__] I'm gonna give it all
to her
[Applause]
man
the butterfly effect of that no you're
just like could you see a little bit
better
[Music]
okay and then so they break up with you
well to be fair sir I don't know
it's quite a political way of saying it
on the crowd Trevor we broke up with
them
on account we don't like what our
significant others [__] other people
[Applause]
so I ended it
okay so they you broke up with him
I like that you're sure about that we
broke up with them [__] I don't get
broken up with
you guys were you meeting up to sort of
commiserate over how silly that was that
that no
app oh you
was it coffee meat donut
and he's like please
she's like I knew you looked familiar I
only saw 10 men on the [__] I
really I remember them all
so you matched on the app then you went
out and that is do you are you I mean by
the way this is like NBC right now is
like oh yeah oh yeah
is there do you ever see your ex
significant other no you're done with
them
no no well yeah I know at the time you
did then you made the terrible move of
basket for someone to scooch
how long when how long ago was that
[__] hey that's so crazy
and you two are they still together no
no they broke up
they went on one date
so they threw it all away for one date
they broke up because they wanted to go
out so bad because of the rail thing
well yeah
not for everybody
that's [__] nut nobody can beat that
right
yeah everyone's like no [__] no okay
that's a pretty good one to be totally
honest
mohawk
good day to you
is it a blue Mohawk yes nice I made him
die
you wow sounds like a great relationship
you found yourself in sir
diet fresh for tonight [__] we're
going out he's like but I'm a rebel diet
I don't like blue
it's my mood hair
I'm feeling blue like my mohawk
how long you had a mohawk sir
holy [__]
[Music]
look he's Statue of Liberty he's
I am the king of the audience
what uh
never never shaved it never gone for
court twice
[Laughter]
tracks
right they're like oh yeah right they're
like well he's just a skinhead he can
live in America
he's okay
what did you go to court twice for
and sort of not
either you don't remember or it's pretty
bad she's like you don't remember us for
bam Slaughter
and then you took all that money from
that gasket you don't remember Mary
what did you say she's like I got it
don't worry I got receipts for this
[__] he dies in blue because he
knows I know where the bodies are buried
diet blue or if I could call the FBI I
got it right nine one diet blue that's
what I thought [__]
you don't have to say what you went to
court for but
been many reasons there's been well so
it's been more than twice that you've
gone to court other times you wore them
[Music]
so you've gone to court a lot of times
since 1992. yes okay I love you I
appreciate your honesty tremendously I'm
enjoying it okay
so yeah okay well we don't know what he
went there for yet you guys might be
killed in a parking lot later so might
be one entrepreneur down he's gonna be
like [__] where's my record buddy
one shop owner dead well it's not him my
buddy's an entrepreneur
[Applause]
can't be him
I was worried I was missing Dan for a
while but he's an entrepreneur
and did you find the treatment for the
from the judge different with the mohawk
s are you finding a lot of this out for
the first time missed you see okay
this is your second time dating in three
years so you mean you had a dating and
then wait a minute do you know those two
people right back there
do they look familiar
Miss were you did you want a better shot
at a concert
where you like to can you get him to
scooch he's like will you scoot um
okay so you've no I want
Adam
can I laugh and he knocked on Tinder a
few weeks later and he's like did you
steal liquor for my friend's New Year's
Eve party yes sir nobody likes an
initiation like that more than me
instead of being like hey how's your
weekend going you just start off with
did you steal liquor from my friend's
party
what prompted the initial breakup if
that's too much you can tell me to [__]
off
you were both drinking too much did you
take liquor from the New Year's party
sir do you think she did
I know let's go by the way you could
tell he's been to court a bunch he's
like just one more thing your honor
so the evidence that I have the evidence
listen to you you're like I've been to
court what this ain't my first rodeo
being a friend brought four bottles of
champagne at this party it was the only
champagne at the party nice her and her
friends show up
40 minutes they leave we go to pop the
bottles there's only three
on Tinder within a week and the first
sentence on our Tinder profile said that
she liked three things I forget what the
first one was but it was something
breakfast burritos and champagne
the defense rests to your honor
the defense rests
not miss it's not great I mean it's
really yeah yeah did you have any
relationships when you took the break in
between the three years oh yeah yeah wow
all right relax sir Jesus Christ she was
like sort of he was like [__] yeah I
mean I really
I put my coffee in the donut you know
what I'm saying I really
together
you've considered it
so yeah I like that she's like that's so
scandalous
my blue Mohawk boyfriend lives in a
courtroom but what you said is shocking
as a bottle of champagne drops her under
her shirt and smashes okay fine
if I can talk in it okay [__]
and I stole the breakfast burrito and
whatever the first thing is
you're the real Tinder swindler that's
what that's where you are
how did you two me
don't nudge each other that's not [__]
you tell him [__] you you tell him 32
frogs ago 32 so you've been together for
32 frogs
uh yeah
Isn't it nice that you have now created
a system of years
32 frogs and nobody laughed everyone was
like oh that's so long
32 frogs
how many frogs you've been married
22 frogs married wow Jesus Christ
how did you meet
Love at Second Sight
you're not getting laid tonight sir I'm
not gonna lie to you judging on her
reaction to like no no no no no no
you're gonna wait half a frog until we
[__] again
anyone hammered
yeah hammered how did you two me
yeah that'll teach you to be
enthusiastic won't it she's like [__] I
just want to say I was drunk what the
[__] no are you together
yes how no
no that's the go-to women we are
together no we're not I mean we
sometimes drink wine and kiss I'm sorry
I've said too much
sometimes happens
she gave you a job what job did she give
you
Easy Does It Now
please
scientists you're both scientists
he's [__] out of here you see him
he's like scientist portion of the show
take [__] care [__] I'm
gonna go
I'm gonna beat up a guy in an alley
now here's where you see how dumb I am
as I attempt to have a conversation with
Scientists about science
what kind of scientists
oh okay I know I actually know a lot
about Olivia declare types
that's amazing
is it true that around five o'clock the
nucleotides gets a little lower
excuse me six around six yeah okay
no no I'm having fun but ocular
nucleotides that's awesome
I was actually reading an article
recently uh about nucleotides
tell me what you think about this a lot
of people think that
nucleotides are not as prevalent
as they were about 10 to 15 years ago do
you
are you noticing that there is a sort of
a scarcity to the
I pronounced it perfectly and dropped
the [__] thing slippery as [__] um I
don't know what happened wouldn't you
think it maybe is in US
you put it in the aglio yeah
the nucleotides go in the aglio yeah
absolutely
[__] is the blue Mohawk guy I really
it's been gone for like an hour I feel
like I miss him he was we were on the
same page
what did you do before coven what was
your calling
what the [__] did any of us do before
covet I don't know
I wasn't even asking you but okay great
yeah I was talking to her yeah
she was in college okay all right don't
get pissed off at her for being in
college she was in college talk to me
[__] I worked at we
so you were working in cannabis he's
right back as soon as cannabis comes up
[Applause]
as soon as scientist was said he was
gone as soon as cannabis was established
his ass was back in the seat
I think he just crawled under the table
for a little while
together friends
live together is there any hint of
hooking up or no you're just platonic
roommates yeah is it just YouTube okay
she wasn't
if she wasn't sober it might happen
so in other words you need her to grease
the wheels a little bit to make a move
what an amazing position you're in where
you like fall off the wagon and I'll
[__] take advantage of you
come on
how long have you been off the booze uh
I quit right before the pandemic well
smart decision
yeah honestly great call because if you
yeah if you feel like you're teetering
and then you go into the panda like the
pandemic opened me up to drinking on
levels where I was like I'm living like
Winston Churchill right now this is not
I gotta be like nothing wrong with the
gin martini before a 2PM Boss Buddy get
your [__] [__] together
what was your drink of choice
wine yeah oh so dangerous also dangerous
because you can be like you're like I
didn't drink too much just two and a
half bottles I mean
I'm okay
and what do you drink this
you like wine well that sucks for her
she's just sitting behind you like how
is it
describe it to me like you could kiss a
little off my tongue if you wanted
suck some tannins off of Mama's tongue
what are you Whispering about sir
sir would you what did you just whisper
to her
your drink is too strong
what an amazing complaint
she's like I got your back [__]
bring it over here
not a problem I had
alone
yep
oh they put you over in the corner they
were like you have anyone with you
you're like no they're like stasher
if I'm gonna look at it like negatively
for myself it was that you couldn't find
anyone to come to my show with you
and that's the reality isn't it
are you alone
get the [__] over there
huh or do you want to go over there
this is how friendships happen
there we go
Miss Take the Long Way really make it as
long
now I feel like I've crisis right at the
crowd
you're the next concession on the friend
is right there you go [__] yeah
there we go magic [__] beautiful and
you're like I actually like to sit alone
to be honest sir so
you left your purse over there just in
case smart I hear there's not a lot of
crime in this town so that's uh
that's a good call by the way you know
who's over there right [__] blue
Mohawk is right over there
you're not gonna see that [__] purse
again
are you kidding me that's champagne
money to those two
what do you do
hairdresser okay what about you lawyer
okay by the way yeah
does he look familiar
yeah
well I guess I could ask you the same
question does he look familiar yeah
both of you could answer the perfect
coupling for this gentleman here the two
things we've talked about with you are
represented right over there
occupationally
what do you do I work with hair and you
I know him from Court okay all right
all right guys I appreciate y'all coming
out for real thank you so much thanks
let me talk to you
I appreciate each other tonight thank
you thanks guys
[Applause]
[Music]
bless your heart I'll see you next frog
all right
[Music]